Building self-driving car has
been a dream of my life and
I've dedicated more
than ten years to it.
If you can build a safer car,
we would save a lot of lives.
But on top of it, it's transformational.
Just imagine instead of owning a car,
you have a little phone and
you summon a car.
And an empty car comes to you, you just
jump in and let's you go somewhere.
And when you don't need it
any more it disappears.
There is an enormous market for
self-driving car engineers.
Lot's and lot's of companies
that you wouldn't suspect have
entered that field and
are massively hiring.
I challenge everybody
here to be part of this.
We're launching in Udacity a [INAUDIBLE]
program called Self-Driving Cars, so
that everyone in the world can
become a self-driving car engineer.
[MUSIC]